في هجوم لاذعه على العسكريين المتمسكين
بالسلطه انتقد قائد قوات الدعم السريعه
السودانيه اللواء محمد حمدانو العسكريين
الذين يسيطرون على مقاليد الحكم في البلاد
مؤكدا انهم يعرضون التنحي للسماحي بانتقال
ديمقراطي في ظل اداره مدنيه وجدد ذكرها
على ان صراعه مع القاده العسكريين الاخرين
الذين اصبح الذي اصبح علنيا في الاسابيع
الاخيره يتمحور حول مساله تسليم السلطه
المدنيين واضاف متحدثا لقوات الدعم السريع
انه لا يوجد خلاف بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ولكن الخلافه يكمن مع الذين يقفون ضد
تسليم السلطه الى حكومه مدنيه نتابع
الدعم السريع في مشكله بين الناس المكرسين
في السلطه الناس القاعدين المكنكشين
والناس دارين يسلموا السلطه للحكومه
المدنيه ده الخلاف بس
لم الحكومه لحكومه مدنيه كامله الدسم
نصل السودان ده نوصل التحول الديمقراطي
حقيقي
من اكثر من 60 سنه
اصلا الدعم القوات المسلحه
حكومه مدنيه تحول ديموقراطي